In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading from the Sinaxadium for July 8, on which we commemorate the Holy Great
Martyr Procopius.
On the 8th of the month we celebrate the memory of the Great Martyr Procopius of Cessaria
and his companions, his mother Thodosia, 12 women of senatorial rank, and the tribunes
Antiochus and Nikostratus.
Shortly after having promulgated edicts of persecution against the Christians in the year
303, Diocletian, it is said, went to Egypt to put down the uprising initiated by the usurper
Achilles.
Once the victory was achieved and his authority confirmed, he traveled to Antioch, with the
majority of the inhabitants had turned from the cult of idols to worship Christ, the only
true God and Savior.
Diocletian offered a sacrifice in the temple of Apollo of Daphne, then returned to the city
to receive the homage of its leading citizens.
An influential pagan woman, Thodosia, who was originally from Jerusalem and the widow
of a Christian named Christopher, came to present her son, Nianius, to the emperor, along
with a great quantity of gold and silver, soliciting the sovereign to take the young man into
his service.
Nianius immediately elicited the sympathy of Diocletian, who named him Duke of Alexandria,
giving him the mission of pursuing the Christians there who were disobedient to the imperial
edicts.
Nianius set forth for Alexandria at the head of two cohorts of soldiers led by the tribunes,
Nikostratus and Antiochus.
They halted at Apamea in Syria and set off again as night fell in order to avoid the heat
of the sun.
They had traveled about thirty miles when a flash of lightning divided the sky and a voice
was heard.
Nianius, where are you going and against whom are you setting out for war?
The voice warned him that the persecution which he was about to inflict on the Christians
would cause his death and his eternal damnation.
Questioned by the good disposition of his conscience, Nianius replied to the voice calling him,
Lord.
An immense crystal cross then shown in the sky and a voice came from it, saying, I am Jesus,
the crucified, the Son of God.
The blessed youth was then instructed in the whole mystery of salvation and Christ added,
since you have seen me, you will become a chosen vessel.
By this sign you will conquer all your adversaries.
My peace be with you.
The vision ended, Nianius hurried to Cithopolis, where he had a Jewish silversmith fashioned
a silver cross following the model which had appeared to him.
Immediately as the cross was completed, three images appeared on it engraved in Hebrew.
On the upper part, Emmanuel was written, on one side, Michael, and on the other side, Gabriel.
He kissed the cross and its images not made with hands, with reverence, and returned to Jerusalem.
Each year, bands of Bedouins looted the town of the region, and carried off the young noble
girls to make them their wives.
That year, as the menace weighed yet again on Jerusalem, the leading citizens of the city
came to beg Nianius to intervene with his troops to defend them.
The saint seized the cross, which until that time he had kept hidden and rushed into battle,
invoking the name of Christ.
More than 6,000 haggarines fell under their blows, but not one of his men was wounded.
Turning to the city, he announced his victory to his mother, who, being a staunch pagan,
attributed it to the protection of the gods, and urged him to offer a sacrifice of thanksgiving
in their honor.
The saint replied that it had been through the power of Christ that he had brought about
the victory, and leading his mother into the room where she kept the family idols.
He reduced them to pieces.
Forgetting all maternal sentiment, Thelidosia went to denounce her son to the emperor, who
charged Olsian, the governor of Caesarea in Palestine, to investigate the matter.
Nianius tore up the imperial letter in front of Olsian, declaring that he preferred to offer
himself in sacrifice for Christ, then to offer vain worship to false gods, and undoing
his belt, he threw it towards the governor with disdain written across his face.
Olsian ordered that he be taken in chains to Caesarea, the capital of Palestine, to be publicly
whipped before all the populous.
As certain of those present wept when they saw him tortured, Christ's courageous athlete
cried out to them, try not for me, but rather for the destruction of your souls.
What advantage is it for us if our body finds rest in this life, but our soul is eternally
damned?
As for me, I rejoice like a sower who sows his seed with the hope of a future recompense.
He was thrown into prison half dead, and as he lay there in his own blood, after having
been tortured for the whole day, Christ appeared to him in glory, accompanied by an angelic
choir.
He freed him from his bonds and said, You shall henceforth be called Procopius, for you
will progress in virtue, arriving at the perfection of martyrdom, and will bring a great number of
souls to God.
The Lord healed all his wounds, strengthening and emboldening him through this vision, and
he was thus ready to endure all sorts of trials visited upon him by the servants of the
demons, so that the truth might be manifest.
The guards came a little later to remove him from prison, and he was taken before the
governor, his face radiant like the sun, and his body untouched like an immaculate sheet.
As Olsian attributed this miracle to the protection of the gods, Procopius, to the governor s great
surprise, himself suggested that he go to the temple to offer a worthy sacrifice to them.
Overjoyed at their victory, the pagans lined the route in white garments, and the heralds
convoked the whole population, arriving at the temple, the saint asked to enter alone
in order to pray.
Closing the doors behind him, Procopius made an ardent prayer to Christ, and as soon as
he made the sign of the cross, 36 statues collapsed and turned to dust.
Before this miracle, the two tribunes, Nikostratos, and Antiochus, as well as other soldiers of
the troop, confessed the true God, fearing a rebellion, the governor was not able to punish
them immediately, so they came to Procopius at night in the prison and asked him to enroll
them in the army of the king of heaven.
Olsius confided them to the jailor Tertius, who was his friend, and who comforted him in his trials,
so that he might take them to Bishop Leontius to be baptized.
Summoned a little later by Olsian, the Neophytes were beheaded before Procopius' eyes,
and buried by Olalius, a respected man of the city.
Twelve women of senatorial rank, who had come to believe in Christ, because of the miracles
wrought by the Holy Martyr, were arrested and thrown into the same prison.
St. Procopius instructed them the whole night in the doctrine of salvation, and exhorted them
not to fear transitory torments, which would deliver them from hell and make them immortal.
In the morning, they were brought before the tyrant in the amphitheater, and ordered to offer sacrifice.
Contemplating the heavenly endurance of these holy martyrs under torture,
Procopius' mother, Thelidosia, was touched by divine grace, and renouncing the glory and every
care of this world she cried out. I, too, am a servant of the crucified.
Throne into prison, she tended the wounds of the twelve martyrs, and was prepared for holy
baptism by her son, who exhorted her to martyrdom, saying to her, come with us, to see the invisible
God in heaven with immortal eyes. Once baptized by Bishop Leontius, she resolutely joined the choir
of the twelve martyrs. After a further appearance before the tribunal, at which Thelidosia made the
most ardent confession of faith, they were all subjected to torture. Their jaws were broken,
their breasts torn off, and their armpits burned by having red-hot balls of iron placed under
them. As they all remained unflinching, the governor had them bound to one another,
and ordered that they be beheaded. A few days later, Saint Procopius was interrogated again,
and while he was being tortured, he cured a little girl tormented by a demon.
He remained under torture as unyielding as a rock beaten by the waves,
so that the governor Olsion, grieved at his defeat, was seized by a violent fever, and died.
Another governor, Flavian, who was as ferocious towards Christians as his predecessor,
was appointed in his place. He immediately summoned Saint Procopius, who pronounced a brilliant
Apollogia for faith in Christ, demonstrating that even the pagan sages had an intuition of the only
true God. Enraged, Flavian ordered the soldier Archelaus to behead the saint. But as soon as he raised
his sword, his hand became paralyzed, and he dropped down dead.
Six days later, the saint was again summoned to the tribunal.
Accused of magic, he offered himself willingly to torture, and under the blows continued to mock
the helpless magistrate. After having beaten him with whips and applied red-hot calls to his body,
Flavian had the saint's hand filled with incense, forcibly placed on the edge of an idolatrous
altar so that under the effect of being burned, he would throw the incense on the altar in sacrifice.
Yet, with all his will, cleaning firmly to God, the saint kept his hand immobile on the furnace
for two hours until the fire was completely burned to ashes. Flavian was amazed at this heavenly
endurance, but, hardening his heart like Pharaoh before him, he handed Procopius over to further
torture. Having been suspended, his limbs distended by two heavy rocks. He was thrown into a burning furnace.
The soldiers who were near the furnace were burned, but the saint remained untouched,
like the three young men in Babylon. Flavian then pronounced the sentence of death.
Arriving at the place of execution, Saint Procopius asked his torturers for the grace of a last
prayer, and turning towards the east, he interceded for the city, that God might send the light
of the knowledge of him to its inhabitants, that he might heal its sick, come to the aid of the
indigent, and bestow his grace on all those who would honor his memory. A heavenly voice indicated
that his prayer had been heard, the saint then peacefully bowed his neck under the sword
to receive the unfading wreath of martyrdom. Through the prayers of our holy fathers,
O Lord, Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us and save us.